One way of setting up live
editing is within your browser.
Some editors, like Brackets,
come with live editing built in.
In Brackets, you press a button
that will launch a new instance of
your browser with your
updates already live.
Sublime Text doesn't have it built in,
but the Takana plugin gets pretty close.
However, it supports CSS and
SCSS live editing, but not HTML.
Chrome DevTools has a relatively
little known feature called Workspaces
that allows you to ditch
the editor altogether and
work directly in the browser.
You can make changes to your CSS
right in the Styles panel, and
have them persist.
The same goes for JavaScript.
There's a link in the instructor's notes
listing all the steps you need to take
to set up Workspaces on your computer.
The fundamental flaw with
live editing in your editor
is that it isn't aware
of your build process.
So be mindful of that.
Browsersync allows us to have live
editing that is assisted by our build
tool, improving upon the two
methods we showed you before.
For this to work, we can reuse something
we've already learned about, and
that's the watch task that currently
watches our Sass for changes and
compiles them into CSS.
Browsersync works by creating or
proxying a local web server which serves
and tracks your files for changes.
Best of all, it's free, open source, and
is compatible with most Node.JS-based
build tools including Gulp.
So let's go ahead and set it up.